Hi, I'm Pegman.
You might recognize me from Street View on Google Maps.
With our new look, Street View's now become a more integrated part of Google Maps.
Let me show you my new home.
Let's explore San Francisco.
Since you're in an area where Street View is available, I've lit up yellow.
To enter Street View, grab me and drop me wherever you like.
Street View is available on any street outlined in blue...
...and thumbnail images appear as you hover over any point on the map.
Hello, Painted Ladies.
You're now exploring a neighborhood in our full screen mode.
Zoom in by double - clicking on the map or by using the button.
And take a 360 - degree tour with the new scroll wheel.
To exit Street View, click on the X in the corner.
You can now also enter Street View just by zooming in to the lowest level on the Google map.
Take a walk down the street by using the white arrows...
...or just pick me up to get where you wanna go faster.
For travel directions, just enter your start and end locations.
And by clicking on the camera icon,...
...you can view Street View imagery of every step of your journey.
Explore your route turn by turn.
You can embed the image in a website or send it to a friend.
Here we are. Sweet!
If you ever find any Street View content that you feel is objectionable,...
...click on "Report a concern" to report any inappropriate imagery.
So whether it's for finding a location or virtual tourism,...
...Street View lets you explore Google Maps like never before.